翻訳: Hiroyuki Sugiura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
みなさんは 本気で楽しんだことが
ありますか？
大人が楽しむと どういうことが起きると
思いますか？
今日は 僕の仕事である写真を使って
お見せしようと思います
こちらの写真をご覧ください
「この写真 一人ひとり 別のところで撮って
うまいこと合成したなぁ」と思われる方は
手を挙げてみてください
結構いますね
俺のこと知らんのかな？
（笑）
現場の動画をご覧ください
（杉山）いい感じでーす
じゃあ いきまーす
お願いしまーす
えーと ボールの方は —
（チーム）（笑）
（杉山）ボールの方は
いち に の さん で投げてください
（女性）ここも？手前も？
（杉山）手前も3.5ぐらいで
投げてほしいですね
（チーム）3.5？ むずかしい
（杉山）じゃ いきまーす
お願いしまーす
表情を派手にしてくださーい
いきます
いち に の さん はいっ！
（歓声）
（メンバーA）あーえらかった
（メンバーB）完璧だ
（メンバーC）同じ方向しか飛んでない
このような楽しい感じの中で
激しい
合成なしの
一発撮りにこだわって 撮影をしています
僕は 主に広告写真を撮っています
広告主である企業で
本当に働いている人たちをモデルに
企業PR写真を撮っています
なぜ 合成したかのような
非現実の世界がつくれるのか？
それは フラッシュにあります
20台ものフラッシュを
いろんな方向から光らせて
この非現実の世界をつくります
フラッシュは 一度光ると
パワーを貯めるのに５秒間かかるので
バシバシバシッと連写はできません
ボールを投げた瞬間
ジャンプした瞬間に
１回だけ撮る
なかなか合いませんから 20回 30回繰り返し
準備から含めると
５時間ぐらいかけて撮影をします
この撮影をするために
会社の皆さんと
綿密な打ち合わせをします
打ち合わせの内容は
絵ではなく 文章で伝えます
絵コンテなどは 描きません
当日 現場に合わせた
自分の中のイメージを
即興でつくります
そのほうが 絵コンテにとらわれない
自由で 自然で 自主性のある
絵づくりになっていくんです
今までは
撮る側の私
撮られる側の皆さんが 別々でしたが
みんなで一緒になって作り上げていく
即興の舞台芸術の様な感じで
盛り上がっていきます
なぜそこまでして合成無しに
こだわるのかがここにあります
合成の有り無しは 写真には写らないと
思ってる方が多いんですが
僕は必ず写ると思っています
緊張感やリアル感が 全然違いますし
みんなで一緒に作るので 素人の方でも
表情が突き抜けてくるんです
このようにして撮った作品を５枚
ゆっくりご覧ください
（笑）
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
うれしいな
僕はこういう楽しい写真を
最初から撮っていたわけではありません
僕が最初のころに撮っていた写真は
こちらです
（笑）
料理の撮影をしていました
僕の父は
広告の写真スタジオをしていたので
長男ですし 仕事が順調だったので
僕も継ぐつもりでした
でも 決められたレールの上を
歩くのが嫌だったので
高校を卒業して
写真よりも車が好きだったので
車の会社に勤めます
事務員が かっこいいと思って始めるのですが
今思えば
何かを創り出す アート志向が強い自分に
似合うはずも無く
すぐにノイローゼになりました
（笑）
人の目線が気になって
人の目が見られなくなる病気です
人生初めてのことで恥ずかしくて
誰にも相談できず
本当に苦しい時期でした
「事務員は無理だぁ」と思って
異動届けを出して
次は塗装の部門に異動します
この方が その塗装の時に
僕の上司だった方で
この方が大変強烈な上司でした
午前中は 塗装の仕事をするんですが
午後は ゴルフの練習をしました
（笑）
塗装の腕前は
一流の職人わざだったので
遊んでいても 仕事は完璧なので
誰も文句が言えないんです
昔はこういう方が １人や２人
会社の中にいらっしゃいましたよね
今だと絶対に無理だと思うんですけど
僕は 会社員というのは
上司の言うことを聞く人が
すばらしいと思っていたんですが
この方は 会社の言いなりではなく
仕事の上ではとても自分らしく
生きていました
とても羨ましかったです
僕は このときに思いました
「自分らしく生きたい」と
与えられた仕事をする
会社というシステムではなく
自分らしく仕事を作り上げる
「自営業だ！」と思って
結局 父の仕事を継ぐことにしました
ここで父の下で料理の撮影を始めます
ただこの頃は
写真の魅力もわかりませんでしたし
どちらかというと
写真は好きではありませんでした
やる気がないので 父と喧嘩したり
クライアントとも上手くいきません
誰でも撮れるような写真を撮っていました
誰でも撮れる普通の写真は
作品の質ではなく
価格の安さで比べられるのです
「そうか みんなと同じ写真を
撮っているから比べられるんだ」
僕はこのときに思いました
「自分にしかできないことを見つけよう」
そうすれば 価格も自由に決められると
人生 負け続けてきたので
そろそろ人生の勝負を打たないと
いけないと思ったときに
ふと頭に浮かんだのが
『企業戦士サラリーマンダム』でした
（笑）
街で「いいやぁ どうも どうも」と
握手している年配のサラリーマンの方を見て
「日本のサラリーマンは
もっとかっこいいはずだ！」
それと
日本を代表するロボットのアニメを見て
正義が勝つ的な 一方的な内容ではなく
主人公が
苦悩しながら強くなっていく
ストーリーに感動して
サラリーマンと
アニメが
頭の中で
ドッキングしたんです
サラリーマンでアニメの名シーンを
再現したら面白いんじゃないかって
静岡市の名所といわれる所で
ゲリラ撮影をします
（笑）
絶対に撮ってはいけないところに入って
バシバシッと撮って逃げるという
過激なことをしていました
（笑）
良い子は絶対に真似しないで ください
ただ
こういうくだらないことをしながら
１つのチャレンジをしていました
それは 技術力の向上です
今までの負けは
この技術力の無さだと気がついて
今の仕事に活きてくる
フラッシュを使い始めるのです
僕は 写真の世界では
プロとアマチュアの差は
フラッシュにあると思います
光をコントロールできるのが プロです
フラッシュで非現実の世界を
つくり出せるんです
僕には サラリーマンで
ゲリラ撮影をするという
発想力はありましたが
技術力がありませんでした
プロというのは
発想力と技術力の両輪があって
初めて走りだせる
その両輪を手に入れるための
勉強の場としての
挑戦でした
『サラリーマンダム』
これが僕の「楽しい」でした
僕の楽しいは
みんなの楽しいか問いたくて
写真展を開催します
すると 沢山の方に集まっていただいて
「とても楽しい」と言っていただきました
僕はこのときに気がつきました
自分が「徹底的に楽しむ」ということが
いかに大事かを
この『サラリーマンダム』が認められて
お仕事図鑑『コドモンデ』を
一緒に作らないかというお誘いを受けます
『コドモンデ』は
静岡市の小学校中学校に配られている
お仕事の学習フリーペーパーです
いろいろな職種がいる人たちを
１枚の写真にして
表紙にしたら面白いんじゃないか
と思って始めます
この集合写真のスタイルが
今の僕の仕事につながっています
会社が嫌でやめてしまった僕が
会社の人たちにエールを送るような
仕事ができていることが本当に幸せですし
僕は 今の仕事が
とても楽しいです
『サラリーマンダム』で徹底的に楽しんだら
自分にしかできない
お仕事図鑑『コドモンデ』が始まって
いつのまにか仕事となり
自分らしく生きられるようになっていました
僕が今まで探してきた
「自分らしく生きる」とは
「自分にしかできないこと」を
「徹底的に楽しむ」ことで
見つかったんです
全部つながっていたんです
徹底的に楽しむことが 必要だったんです
最後に
アニメの名シーンを再現した
こちらの作品をご覧ください
プロレスの技です
修正すらしていない 完全一発撮りです
（笑）
どのようにして撮ったかご覧ください
（杉山）まだ最初は見えてていいからね
後ろのサポートは
（男性A）いくよー せーの！
（ゆうた）あっ！ あっ！
まだ まだ行ける
（スタッフ）OK はい
（杉山）今 こうへい君見えてる状態
（杉山）もっと上げてください もっとー
（男性B）どうだ？
（杉山）もっとー ハイOK 行こう
（男性A）脚 少し反るよー
（女性）ゆうた 顔
（女性）ゆうた君 顔[上げて]
（杉山）はい 行くよー せーのーで
（杉山 ）はーい 足どけてよー
（男性A）よっしゃー
（杉山）よーしOK OK あーっていう顔ね
（男性A）あー！ぐぁー！
（杉山）よーし
（男性A)しゃ おらー　しゃー おらー
（杉山）下村くんもうちょい 脚しめて
（男性A)しゃー おらー
そろそろ来いやー
（スタッフ笑）
（杉山）終わり終わり終わり
（男性A）しんどいんじゃあー
（杉山）終わり！
（女性）お疲れさまです
（スタッフ）あー
（男性 叫ぶ）
（女性）ありがとー
（笑）
（拍手）
ものすごくバカでしょ？
（笑）
子どもの頃は
この技がどうしても再現できなかった
大人になったら再現できたんです
大人は 楽しんじゃいけない
楽しむは 子どもの専売特許だと
思われている方が多いですが
大人だって楽しんでいいんです
大人が楽しむと タチが悪いですよぉ
子どもとは比べものになりません
知識と経験で 不可能を可能にできる
徹底的に楽しんでください
ただ
まあまあ楽しいとかはダメです
まあまあ楽しいとかは
みんなが真似できます
そうじゃなくて
自分のむちゃくちゃ楽しい
最上級の楽しさを探して下さい
みなさんは
徹底的に楽しいを
とことん追求したことは ありますか？
「楽しいことはわからないなぁ」という方は
楽しくないことを一つ一つ手放してみるのも
いいかもしれません
自分にしかできないことを見つけたい人は
自分の楽しいに一点集中してみてください
一点の方が壁をぶち破りやすいから
みなさん一人ひとりの
徹底的に楽しんでいる世界を
僕は見てみたいです
自分の楽しいが見つかったら
作品や 商品や 仕事や イベント
何らかの形にして 世の中にシェアします
「僕の楽しいは
みなさんの楽しいですかぁ？」って
僕が楽しんで撮った写真は
僕が楽しいだけではなく
見てくれた方が「元気になる」って
言ってくれたんです
自分が楽しかっただけの写真は
なぜか みなさんのためにもなってました
不思議ですね
楽しむということは
時や
場所や
意味や
理由を
選びません
もっと言うと
楽しいは
恵まれている
いない
時間がある
ない
知識がある
あなただからできる
私にはできない
そんなものは関係ありません
楽しんで楽しんで楽しんで
楽しくないを
手放して
楽しんで楽しんで楽しんで
周りがとやかく言うけど
自分のことを信じて楽しんで
楽しんで楽しんで楽しんで
最上級の楽しさを見つけたときに初めて
自分らしさがあると思います
（拍手）